ورددتنا قبل قليل صور
للحظات الاولى لوقوع الزلزال وهي في
مستشفى في اضنه
اذا هذه صور مباشره قبل قليل في لحظه وقوع
الزلزال في اضنه والذي
قيل بان مركزه كان في بلده دفتي على بعد
سته فاصل اربعه عشره معنى سلام خضر من
اضنه
سلامنا هل لديك معلومات جديده نحن نبط
الان هذه الصور التي وردتنا قبل قليل من
من اضنه هو هذا المستشفى ولحظه وقوع
الزلزال في هذه اللحظات هل لديك معلومات
جديده سلام
السلطات المحليه في اضنه لم تعلن حتى الان
عن وقوع اضرار او اصابات جراء الزلزال
الذي شعر به سكان مدينه اضنه وشعرنا به
ايضا كان عنيفا وكان طويلا هذا ادى الى
نزول عدد كبير من السكان الى خارج الى
اخلاء المباني والنزول الى الشوارع وايضا
ان كنت تلاحظ هناك حركه السير كثيفه عدد
كبير من العائلات
استقل سيارته ويحاول الابتعاد قدر الامكان
عن المناطق التي تتواجد فيها ابنيه عاليه
وايضا يتركون منازلهم خشيه من وقوع الاسوا
لا سمح الله اضن تاثرت بالزلزال الاول
الذي ضرب البلاد قبل اسبوعين سقط فيها عدد
من القتلى ايضا عدد من المباني تدمر في
المدينه ولكن هذا الزلزال لم يحدث اي
اضرار حتى الان بحسب السلطات المحليه يا
جمال